you are doing so well in terms of
isolation because you're doing cooking
videos your friend Johnny is scaring you
all the time you're playing tetherball
you're making music like it seems like
you're handling it pretty good we are I
am trying to my best of my ability guys
the moments you don't see right Mental
Health Awareness Month um the moments
you don't see in between all that it's
like I'm feeling all sort of anxiety I'm
having all sorts of feelings so those
are there I'm just trying to cope with
them in ways like finding joy and having
a good time and you know I think we're
all trying to do that but yeah we're
trying you know you make the best of it
yeah and that's the way to do it right
when you have those moments mentally
it's just finding something to keep it
positive and it's so good that you are
doing that and you're making us laugh so
I don't have to tell you since I'm
talking about your performance at the
Oscars were absolutely amazing your
voice was so beautiful and what was that
moment like for you actually thank you
um whoo y'all it was scary
you know I think in my mind I was like
oh this is fine like it's no big deal
but leading up to what my stomach was
like in knots the whole week and I was
like oh those are feelings that I'm
having I guess I am nervous because I
want to do a good job you know and I
want to honor of course the story and
the song and Diane and who knows if I
ever will have that opportunity again on
an Oscar stage so it was exciting it was
super fun it happened in a flash I was
like where did it go like two minutes
and thirty seconds of my life so it was
wonderful though yeah and I understand
that you auditioned for American Idol
are you happy you didn't work out yes
listen I believe it happens for a reason
for sure but you know music being
something I've always wanted to do I was
like oh I'll give it a go the old
American Idol try and it wasn't my path
folks what's not my path I mean I'm glad
I got to the actual you know the
position that I got to you and it wasn't
without you know I literally had to say
I think
the guy who auditioned me I was like I
think you're making a wrong decision
because he told me no initially it's in
my book and so if anybody's yeah read it
I hate to be redundant however he then
says okay
and there was two women next to him
auditioning other people and they were
like come over and come over and sing
for us and I was like okay I got a
second chance so luckily they said yes
and they saw something that was
interesting but yeah like everything
happens as as it should and I don't know
if I could hack that show I want to say
I think it's too much pressure that kind
of reflects it to your new song talking
to God right you listen to this it's
Brian emotional and the thing I got from
it was forgiveness there's something
about this song that really resonated
with me what does this song mean to you
well so I you know when I first heard it
I didn't co-write this one but when I
heard it I thought okay I live this yeah
and it looks like I'm just married
previously I know what it's like to make
decisions and or not make decisions that
we regret not making you know all of
those things and how we grow as humans
and how we evolve but you know the line
was you know I'm still there's like a
very thin line between moving on and
forgiveness like I truly believe that
forgiveness is something that you do for
yourself and that is so important
because we tend to hold on to
resentments and as they always say like
that's like drinking the poison
expecting the other person to be sick so
it's you know it's we get to learn from
our mistakes and we get to forgive
ourselves and other people and keep
moving so yeah I love that I love the
song I love the sentiment and it was
something that I was like I want to tell
their story please I want to sing it so
I love it it's so beautiful I think it's
the right time to release it now at a
time like this it really does help put a
funk it I mean so crazy but art does
that you know it kind of appears when we
need it so mm-hmm
who do you turn to when you need someone
to talk to who's that person that's your
I guess your rock honestly he's probably
Donnie as yeah and craziest as we might
seem we are similar and a lot of our but
different and so we're different enough
and he'll you know talk me down when I
need to be talked down or you know give
me some perspective that I can't seem to
find and we've known each other for
eighteen years I think he knows me
better than probably anyone and he's you
know to know him is to love him and he
just helps in any regard so I mean aside
from my sisters it would be Donnie for
sure yeah yeah I thought you like sold
music to you're into soul music right
you're more abhi yeah well you really
see more music that's kind of that buy
well you know there's I mean the way
that country is sort of it's derived
from you know like some people might not
know this but a banjo was actually an
African instrument I came from Africa
right and so just the evolution of
country music there are so many
beautiful like rhythm and blues and
underlining undertones and I'm
influenced by so many different genres
of music that it's like I could never
pinpoint one but country for me feels
like I can incorporate all the
instruments that I love with the
storytelling but who knows you know
artists you know change and want to go
different directions all the time but I
gotta get my country on them first a lot
of people right now in isolation this is
will make you cry non-stop do you watch
it as a fan are you binge watching the
show I have listened I've seen every
single episode you guys and I know that
sounds like oh my god I just I don't get
to see so you know there's so many
different storylines so I don't always
get to see it all together when I'm just
shooting the scenes with Chris or
whatever and so putting it seeing it all
together and then with the music which
it becomes its own you know character
I'm like oh yes I cry Donnie and I
literally like he's like are you crying
I'm like I'm crying I'm the new buddy
like we just can't you I feel like if
you're a human being who was allowing
the emotions to be accessed you can't
help but get emotional
yeah oh my gosh and you guys had a zoom
reunion party as well a lot of people
are doing that with their sick Cosby
kind of seeing each other again how was
that for you was it a great good good
feeling to be connected with everybody
again honestly I'm like this hi guys I
couldn't get close enough you know you
see I see them 1213 hours a day and then
we don't know when we're gonna get back
to production so it's like there's that
longing and just you know you miss their
friends and their opinions every single
day with you know your deepest emotions
that you bring out so yeah it was super
cute and fun and everybody's doing well
and Chris and Rachel have a baby coming
soon and I'm so excited I can't believe
so he's gonna be a real dad
you know I'm just so excited for them
and excited for Mandy's music and yeah
it's just so great to see I think
goodness for technology yeah I know
right
who dominates those conversation who
talks the most in your group golly you
know Justin actually the one who
coordinated it and it was sweet I know
he's not just a pretty face guys he's
not just talented honestly has one of
the biggest hearts he's like such a
great dad and he was like guys do we
miss each other can we like get on a
zoom call we're like oh yes so um he
sort of pound it in a way but we all you
know respectfully give each other enough
chitchat time that's a nice way to say
hear from each other I don't think
anybody bulldozes or anything you know
your character has so many different
spectrum and I think so many people who
relate on different levels but for me to
see you take on the role what did you
learn about yourself being Cate holy
smokes well I realized that I used to be
Kate you know I used to have a lot of
guilt and shame that I'm still working
on about whatever might be but just like
you know that you take things from your
childhood into your adulthood you know
that logically but then when you start
to see it play out and you understand it
in a different way you're like holy
smokes there are some things I have not
dealt with I am NOT contended with you
know and for me as many people now
I didn't have that relationship that
Jack and Kate had I never had that was
my father
okay and so you realize like oh it's
beautiful that I get to sort of live
through that and through the character
through the writing but so doesn't you
know fill that void so I need to learn
about the things that I still I'm still
processing and yeah yeah I mean that's
the whole reason I think we do art yeah
and you it's fascinating to be c.push oh
there's a delay come back to me Chrissy
there you are I hope so but with your
book this is me your memoir that you
released a few years ago you it's about
your life taking on this role of Kade
and I understand at one point you had 81
cents in your your pocket before taking
on this role and this is us what are you
most grateful for especially at a time
like this I mean it would be my health
right that is first and foremost and
that is something that you know we jump
out of bed we try to get to our first
appointment we get on set we whatever it
is that we have to do through the day
yeah I really I've always tried to be
aware and cognizant of okay here's
another day and that I get to have
helped me like guide my actions and my
thoughts and my words and like how many
do you do thy will and help me to be a
good person and just be in gratitude
before we start before I start my day
I'm just like I'm just so grateful that
I get to wake up and then I have my
faculties and I'm healthy you know it's
it sounds silly but like so it's so true
and before I even try to start the day I
start with a gratitude list and I and
it's true that like the more grateful
you are the more you receive which is
such a beautiful concept and I've
noticed it working in my life so yeah I
think it's health thinking um you know
friends family people that you love and
hang in love so does this mean you're
gonna be pursuing
more music than acting going a choice
I'm I just I luckily had time during
hiatus
I sold a movie to Amazon this beautiful
movie true story of a woman who hiked
Kilimanjaro with 300 pounds and I met
her on my book tour a couple years ago
next way yeah so I'm super excited about
that and it wasn't gonna go during this
hiatus potentially hopefully maybe next
so I have time and I was like okay the
universe afforded me this time I really
want to focus on music and I had been
coming back and forth to Nashville for
almost two years on my own dime just
trying to do music cuz that's what I've
always wanted to do and so it just it
just happens that music happens to fall
right now and I was going to do a an
independent film to this month but
because of everything going on so no I I
want to do and I have to do both I got
to do a zoom reading of a film which was
so special I was like oh my gosh it's
only been a couple months and I really
miss acting like you know and music I
mean we're telling a story it's acting
you know to some degree but just as
myself so no I can't
would never want to decide on either
I'll just keep going on both you're so
brilliant at both yeah well why not this
is us wants to know because of the fast
board we don't see Kate everybody's so
concerned about Kate where's like a
alive she could be at the dry cleaners
y'all she could be at the grocery store
listen listen even if she was or say for
instance Jack is not living but he's
never going anywhere so not to fret
nobody's ever gonna go away
nobody's ever gonna go away
so don't worry okay it's like we're so
involved